[Music]
hello my name is blake crab and it is my
pleasure to have here with us today
doctor Gerhardt Strauss er dr. Strauss
er is professor emeritus from the
University of California in San Diego
where he taught for 27 years and he is a
graduate with a PhD from the University
of Munich he actually graduated summa
laude and is one of the youngest
PhDs ever from that University dr.
Strasser is associated with many
prestigious scientific and health
organisation throughout the world
including a member of the American
Institute of nutrition the American
Association of cancer research the
association of clinical scientists
you're a fellow of the American College
of nutrition among many other accolades
you are the director also of your own
biological trace element research
laboratory and are the founder and
editor-in-chief of a magazine by the
same name the biological trace element
and research magazine I've seen a list
of over 300 publications I think there
were three hundred six different
publications that you have written for
different journals and I don't think
that's all of a visit that's not all
around up he's reading in peer-reviewed
journals and you're also an author and
co-author of six different books that's
why it's a pleasure to have you with us
today dr. Chasseur dr. Chasseur tell us
a little bit about your background
obviously you've been interested in
nutrition for a long time no where were
you born
yes well I was born actually in the
middle of Europe in a famous bohemian
spa which was founded in the 18th
century and then frequented by royalty
and famous people during the next
century
it's called Francis but it is about 30
miles east of another famous park called
Cal spot and it's about 20 miles north
of another famous spot called marine
baths these were wonderful centers of
health you might say in the nineteenth
century but thousands of people were
coming and what if they do they drank
mineral waters for health and this is
what got me interested in trace elements
in the
very very early age in my life because
we had a hotel and many of our visitors
wrote down in the guestbook how much
they were helped by taking minerals in
these mineral waters and because of
after the war I couldn't go to school so
I joined a Research Institute as a young
boy actually in age of 14 that did
nothing but study trace minerals in
mineral waters and soil so this is how I
got a thirst and very deep insight into
both chemistry in trace element and
health-related aspects which sure
remained with me all my life and believe
it or not in my hometown was an area
where plant derived minerals qalaat
minerals you could actually see how they
form and when I was just 16 years old I
analyzed colloidal minerals from that
source and found later that some colored
mineral products planteth minerals have
very similar composition that gave me of
course the contact was dr. Joe voila
because dr. Joe Walla came to me place
the bottling plant derived minerals on
my desk and said I want you to analyze
this and then I realized I had done this
years before as a young man and he says
solutions were actually quite similar
chemically what are some of the unique
chemical characteristics of planet
narrows well it is the combination of
the elements and some of the additional
substances that are present basically
sulfur compounds were just making them
so very unusual and helpful and that's
why we are seeing such wonderful effects
many people report astonishing
improvements of their house nothing
helped for example against the bed back
then they drink plant derived Middletons
relatively in a short time they are much
better now medical science would frown
upon such stories and I was skeptical to
myself but I had problems with my back I
believe it or not if I'm permitted to
tell this testimony earlier it helped me
so fantastically that today I can carry
any kind of luggage
unsymmetrical II was one hand or the
other and I haven't had any back
problems since and believe me nothing
else really helped before that and we
know now why they're serious actually
why this helps through the research I've
done with the plant derived minerals it
has to do with the sulfur content and
the other minerals that are present that
the body is able to produce chondroitin
sulfate which is a rubber like polymer
which helps the spine to remain rigid
under stress and obviously when you get
older you may not produce chondroitin
sulfate polymers rapidly enough and then
you get slip disc and all kinds of
problems is your back so this is a very
brief the biochemical basis of some of
the effects of the plant derived
minerals these are not all but some of
them and very important and that
explains what always puzzled me why so
many people said it would help them so
much was that that problem you mention
the sulfur compounds is that what gives
many plethora minerals the astringent
bitter taste that is also true yes that
and some of the minerals present iron
and aluminum and so forth
recently you've been involved in a
historic movement to get the FDA the
Food and Drug Administration in America
to recognize some of the benefits of a
particular trace of mineral we know a
selenium yes and you know if I may say
so the FDA does not allow that anyone
could make a health claim about anything
you couldn't say for example that
selenium helps against certain forms of
cancer unless you could prove it the
demand sufficient scientific evidence so
on the recommendations of dr. Waller
we accumulated approximately 500
scientific papers and submitted them to
the FDA and we were able to get the
approval for two health claims the first
one is that selenium can reduce the risk
of certain forms of cancer and the
second is that selenium produces
anti-cancer substances in the human
organism and this
a quite significant achievement and it's
purely altruistic also because other
companies may use this kind of
information but at least now we can help
people recognize the value of selenium
and I think this is most important
because the intake of selenium in many
populations is insufficient to maximise
its protective effects tell us a little
bit about that dr. Shah sir tell us
about the selenium levels in the various
countries that you've seen research from
or done research in yourself that's
right you see the selenium works on many
different physiological levels and one
level for example is an enzyme called
glutathione peroxidase and that is an
enzyme that prevents the accumulation of
hydrogen peroxide and of lipid hydro
peroxides that is basically oxidized
fatty substances in our organism now
these substances lipid hydro peroxides
and hydrogen peroxides have the nasty
habit that they can decompose forming
very very destructive oxygen radicals so
called hydroxyl radicals and these
hydroxyl radicals will attack anything
and proteins and roll attack fats it
will attack even DNA and the letter
damage is of course the most serious
ones because if you get damaged DNA you
can mutations and ultimately even help
in the progression of a normal cell into
a cancer cell and that's why people I've
measured glutathione peroxidase in the
blood and they determined the amount of
selenium that we need on the activity of
glutathione peroxidase in our plasma and
on the basis has either derived certain
recommended dietary allowances however
we have found that this is not
sufficient that selenium there in fact
23 or by now even 25 other Celino
enzymes in the body and some of them
become activated only at relatively
higher dosages and so in determining the
RDA for selenium
Britta's Amber oxidase is now recognized
as not being
you have to think of other enzymes and
one of them are the so called theory
dachshund reductase is now sounds very
chemical what it is is that there are
certain small molecules that contain
sulfur and they can be oxidized and
reduced small proteins and they called
the thyroid auxins and they are very
important in the transfer of electrons
within the cell and within organs and
when this process doesn't work very well
then you can imagine there is havoc in
the entire organism and one enzyme the
so called the fire reduction reductase
will catalyze the reduction of oxidized
thyroid auxins
back into their active reduced form and
that is a selenium dependent enzyme and
that becomes activated only at
significantly higher selenium intakes
then recommended now based on Twitter
found upstairs alone so you're saying
that we have a lot of free radical
damage that's kind of like rust of
ourselves like just as iron rusts or you
see an apple that starts to turn brown
that had the same kind of activity can
happen in ourselves and one of the
things that helps prevent that if
there's actually an enzyme that our body
produces that require selenium and that
selenium enzyme helps prevent that
there's a certain level that the
government has recognized in most
countries that we need a certain amount
of level of selenium before this one
enzyme but you're saying that there's
actually 23 to 25 different enzymes they
you swim so we actually need a lot more
you see these recommendations were made
before some of these enzymes were
actually discovered and because there's
a certain inertia with all these
agencies that don't meet every year they
don't want to change their
recommendations all the time so now we
know that there's this other enzyme at
least the thigh reduction reductase and
that one is a so-called inducible enzyme
in fact it becomes active only at higher
levels at levels at which glutathione
peroxidase is already maximized thyroid
auxin reductase maybe still no and so
you can increase the selenium intake
of course the ferredoxin reductase
activity and that is why leading
scientists among myself now say we need
significantly more selenium than just
frog glutathione peroxidase the result
is so that varisty recommended dietary
allowances are now at around 50 to 55
micrograms per day we're actually saying
the human body needs 350 micrograms per
day and this is actually recognized that
by our governmental agencies this is
considered the maximum safe selenium
intake so they acknowledge yes you can
have higher dosages of selenium every
day and 350 we say to be absolutely safe
conservative at the same time is around
350 right and so this is why I'm
recommending and this goes back to
overcome cancer that our selenium intake
should in fact reach that level of 300
to 350 micrograms a day why do I know
this well we actually collected blood
from many countries and then we
discovered that in populations were
certain cancers like breast cancer lung
cancer prostate cancer and colon cancer
is low they all had quite nice selenium
levels in their blood which were
proportional to the selenium intakes and
which brought their selenium index in
the order of 300 to 350 microgrammes
de-rezzing countries where you had just
50 to 100 micrograms per day of selenium
these types of cancer very variably
quite high let's talk about two of those
countries in specifics let's talk about
Australia and Japan what are the daily
intake of selenium that people get in
their diets in Australia versus Japan
and the corresponding cancer rates in
those two countries we actually went to
Japan and got blood samples and found
that the Japanese have very nice blood
selenium levels ranging between 20 27
and point 30 micrograms
and cubic centimeter whereas in
Australia and only point 13 which only
about 1/3 of that and this corresponds
to selenium intakes forum let's an
average adults of 70 kilograms in Japan
of about 300 micrograms per day was in
Australia only about a hundred
micrograms per day now mind you hundred
micrograms a day will not give Albert
science what scientists we call selenium
deficiency syndrome and we will talk
about these later so clinically they may
at the moment look healthy because they
have enough to saturate glutathione
peroxidase activity but they don't have
enough for other protective functions of
selenium and that brings us into the
cancer range you see selenium protects
against cancer by many different
mechanisms one is for instance the
immune system and the immune system
requires more selenium it can cause
about 200 to 300 micrograms today why do
I know this I know this because I've
done studies in some patients that need
artificial nutrition intravenous
nutrition they add selenium to the
mixture but only about 50 micrograms
whose room to be about the RDA and these
people had very low antibody production
against common antigens and that is very
important when these people were given
200 micrograms extra selenium they are
antibody production increased up to
tenfold so there you have already one
example that the recommended dietary
allowances were limited to only one
parameter till December oxidase and they
totally ignored the immune system why
was that well because at the time all
these regulations were made people who
are not all that interested in the
immune system but we now know of course
much more about the immune system we
know for example that we have cells that
destroy foreign invaders bacteria and
viruses these are the so called
cytotoxic cells derived from the
specialized white blood cells
these produce oxygen radicals to destroy
invaders and other tumor cells but they
have to have enough selenium to do this
well or else to destroy themselves and
so studies have shown if you give people
additional selenium they're cytotoxic
cells can destroy up to five times more
tumor cells than those who just get
their normal out the I of selenium of
the eye of Salonga so when you're saying
additional selenium how much additional
we're talking they get some selenium in
their diet and then they supplement with
additionally that's right and I think
it's a good thing to now say we need
about 200 to 300 micrograms extra we
don't really need more and that brings
us into the level of the maximum safe
intake that is recommended by the
Institute of nutrition and other
agencies so now that shows you that our
recommendation is ethical in other words
you don't have to worry about toxicities
well proven that this produces no unsafe
levels of whatsoever for the entire
lifespan right and doesn't adversely
affect any physiological function
because you will wonder how toxic is
selenium and many people still think
selenium is a poison historically this
is because selenium became known as a
poison for the first time in the
twenties in the United States are some
high selenium regions and when they had
cattle grazing in these regions they
developed diseases attributed to
selenium toxicity for example horses
would lose their hooves and farmers
Africa terribly alarmed you know
poisonous soil poisonous plants and then
they found it is selenium and the US
Department of Agriculture did extensive
studies in these regions to find out how
they were located and especially also
whether they would do damage to humans
so I can say that selenium from the
toxicological point of view is probably
the best investigated trace element ever
but they found no evidence in these high
selenium regions South Dakota is one New
Mexico of any damage to human health so
the unfortunate image of selenium as a
poison was only for animals not for
humans but this carried on over the
years and when my friend Klaus Schwartz
showed 1957 that selenium was an
essential trace element initially people
threw up the arms and so my god
selenium the poison suddenly needed by
the human organism and so for a while it
was called the essential poison we now
know of course that all our elements are
basically safe at a certain level and
become toxic and higher levels is true
even for what and too much water can
kill you too much oxygen can kill you so
we shouldn't worry about this as long as
we know the safe window isn't it true
that the safety issue is also affected
by some balancing nutrients they think
with selenium zinc and copper and
they're helped people to achieve the
balance in their bodies with higher
levels of selenium that's right and the
physiological effects of selenium also
depend on how much protein you eat if
you give experimental animals a high
selenium diet that would be toxic in the
normal condition you can abolish the
toxicity of your protein intake is also
increased protein intake of these
animals so it is a balance also between
the sulfur amino acids in the food and
selenium and that's why you know all the
concerns about selenium toxicity are
really unwarranted selenium has an
excellent safety record in fact and
practically no nobody was ever seriously
poisoned well you've also been a
visiting professor in it twice in China
and twice in Japan tell us about some of
the research on selenium that's come out
of those areas yes I was especially
interested in another selenium
deficiency disease we know the Chinese
discovered cashaan disease which is a
cardiomyopathy and we will talk a little
bit more about that but then there's
another one and the so-called crushing
BEC syndrome
in which children cease growing because
the actively growing part of the bone is
atrophied and stops growing and so they
remained dwarfs and when you visit some
of the regions and Xian you still see
patients sitting in corners small Dwarfs
that have cash in back syndrome research
showed that selenium can prevent
significantly the cash in BEC syndrome
and I went there and we did some
research and we found that some
additional elements play a role in this
disease as well the deficiency for
example in iodine a boron very
interestingly which Mino also helps bond
formation and then interesting enough a
highly neglected element germanium which
is in some of the colloidal plant
derived minerals also so here you have
example of synergistic interactions it's
not selenium alone is important you
gotta watch the other ones too and they
have to be given in the dinars tell us
about some of the conditions that you've
seen selenium help with I know you've
talked about bleeding fevers yes
hemorrhagic fever which is a terrible
disease with an extremely high mortality
eighty percent mortality and that also
occurs in some parts of China and it has
a viral origin and these people
basically bleed to death and there was a
Chinese doctor in during an epidemic of
hemorrhagic fever would deciding you've
got to do something about it these
people were dying so he gave these
people selenium and relatively high
dosages and he could actually lower the
mortality from 80% in the acute phase of
the disease to about 20% should from
endless success as some of this
wonderful Chinese research goes
completely unnoticed in the West and
this is why I actually created a May
special award for such research as the
class Schwartz award and the doctors
name was dr. who
Hou and he was a recipient of that medal
at the end of that medal you've also
seen
benefits of selenium with teeth and even
eyesight I've heard that's right we've
done studies in patients and gave them
selenium and then by questionnaire the
80% or so reported improvements of their
vision and you see the eye has very high
selenium concentrations and in fact as a
comparative studies have shown that in
animals that better an animal can see
the higher than its selenium content is
and fences cats have very highly a very
good eyes and the selenium content in
the eye is very high and so I guess it
isn't very very important for our vision
in the case of teeth the dentin is a
sort of protein which the sulfur Ridge
and it requires selenium to be formed
properly and so selenium is one of the
so-called anti cariogenic trace elements
in prevents carriers then they striking
proof of this was a comparative study of
the teeth of antique Greeks they had
perfect teeth no cavities nothing
compared to modern Athenians of shocking
teeth was a lot of carriers and they
showed that the antique Greeks had three
times more selenium in dead Entine than
the present-day Greeks now you will say
why he said well it has to do with
dietary changes they eat much more sugar
now the sugar was unknown as such in
antiquity and they eat more grains of it
simply a healthier diet at that time
which gave him automatically more of
selenium so it's an anti cariogenic
agent now let's go down in the body in
through the side rod the selenium is
needed for the proper function of the
thyroid and why is that they have these
Tsai roid hormones and there are
inactive forms
they're called t4 and that's the
molecule as for iodine in it tyrosine
amino acid ms for either and that has to
be converted to t3 with only three high
dines and there's an enzyme which does
that and that enzyme requires selenium
so it now happens and they discovered
that as some people may have a normal
thyroid hormone production they cannot
somehow produce t3 and they didn't know
how this came about until they found
that these people needed additional
selenium to produce enough of that
enzyme to affect this D iodization so
now let's go down even further let's go
to the heart as we all agree a very
important organ and the heart cells
contract rhythmically that's the marvel
the miracle of the heart cells and this
contractile function requires selenium
so normally the heart should be rich in
selenium if you make the heart hello in
selenium and you develop cardiomyopathy
which can be fatal
may I tell you now a personal story
which I have a which I haven't told you
yet or seldom anyone says I told you I
was born there in the center of Europe
and at that time they didn't know that
it was a selenium deficiency region
there was something peculiar in my youth
I couldn't run very well I always had
trouble running and when I then went to
Germany joined the University we have to
have a medical exam and we got an x-ray
and suddenly all these medics called all
the physicians look at this guy he has a
so-called athlete's heart at that time
people called anyone with an enlarged
heart an athlete's heart because they
saw it off men people who exercise a lot
I didn't do much exercise I told you I
couldn't run very well I actually had
the beginnings of kishan disease and by
taking selenium my heart has normalized
in size because it turns out my home
town is in a low selenium region and
that brings me what I mentioned before
to the very important effect of selenium
and viruses they couldn't quite work out
why some of the children in the Kishan
diseases died while others did not until
they found out that in the heart of most
people are actually viruses which are
normally benign
so-called coxsackieviruses that at least
seven different variants of these
viruses and they are what we call cardio
philic viruses they will lodge
specifically in the heart
they won't do you much harm or any harm
but if your selenium intake is low then
we know that you get Mork surgeon
radical production now these oxygen
radicals will not only damage your heart
cell they will also damage the virus the
Coxsackie virus and what was a benign
non pathogenic virus will suddenly
become violent and destroy the heart so
is that why there's a lot of doctors now
when somebody has a heart disease they
say you've got a bacteria or a virus
lodged in your heart you know you picked
that up somewhere it was actually there
all the time
exactly it triggered it and it can also
be triggered by other environmental
influences for example they found in in
Germany that people were exposed to
mercury had a higher incidence of
cardiomyopathy how is that possible well
selenium will react with mercury in the
body
mercury in activates the necessary
enzymes so again we are going back to
selenium here so this is the great story
of selenium in the heart and so cash on
disease is not a pure selenium
deficiency but it also has to do with
viruses and that brings us now the
absolutely wonderful effect of selenium
against viruses have the studies were
done by Melinda Beck and American
researchers and she now has also found
this is true for influenza virus that
means there are different forms of
influenza virus which defined in how
much damage they do and she's shown that
in selenium deficiency a mildly active
influenza virus would become more
virulent so selenium is in fact also a
natural antiviral agent and that even is
true for the AIDS virus and there now in
the United States
studies that show or are in the process
of looking at the effects of selenium in
AIDS patient know those studies involve
much higher levels of slinging that even
we've been talking about isn't it much
of beyond even the 300 ad no not
necessarily that's still physiological
and you know we did research with AIDS
patients years ago because I in fact was
the first one who recommended selenium
supplementation to AIDS patients and in
fact this has been subsequently studied
and we did this ourselves and we found
symptomatic improvement of AIDS patients
with selenium well since the French have
shown that the cardiomyopathy of AIDS
patients can be alleviated by giving
them selenium and dr. montagnier one of
the co-discoverer of the AIDS virus he
actually also always recommended
something has to be done against the
oxygen radical production in HIV
infected subjects because that increases
the pathogenicity of their virus so
selenium and viruses who would have
thought that suddenly but always you see
it's again the higher dosage level that
we need optimally for protection
selenium is not just a trace element
that is essential
it also has protective functions and for
that you need more in other words you
need a little reserve okay let's go down
to the liver also as we all will agree a
very important organ and the liver also
should be normally rich in selenium and
in fact hain animal studies have shown
that a healthy animal will have high
levels of selenium in the liver and in
fact when one of the first studies that
was done by Klaas Zwart when he made
experimentally low selenium diets when
he fed those two rats these rats were
developed within two weeks young rats a
faithful liver necrosis in other words
the liver would simply
and that actually led to the discovery
of the sensuality of selenium and
happens sometimes in humans I myself
once sir was asked to help in a case of
a serious alcohol ik he had no
detectable levels of selenium in his
blood and he had a very severely damaged
liver so he was given large doses of
selenium and he had a very very
remarkable recovery I've noticed with my
own mother that she had a lot of liver
spots and when she started supplementing
with extra selenium with the rest of the
90 essential nutrients then those liver
spots on her face all faded away and
started disappearing from her arms in
the back of your hands as well that's a
very good point what are these liver
spots they're caused by basically
oxidized fat and they they are called
hypo fasting and this caused by oxygen
radical production she then give
selenium after a while these oxygen
radicals no longer produced and the
spots will disappear so this skin in
other words requires selenium and that
of course also has to do now fear if you
add to this immune system can there be
any wonder that selenium is a protecting
agent against certain forms of cancer
this becomes quite clear now tell us a
little bit about the shrouds reward
you've got a special award out now for
people who do research on selenium tell
us a little bit about what that
represents and some of the studies that
have come out from people that you've
awarded this to right well actually
there's another of these stories of mine
which I haven't yet told very much I
once was invited to Germany to talk to
former cancer patients you know that is
self-help organizations and I arrived
there late in the evening and before I
left my hotel in Switzerland and I had
some selenium supplements on my desk put
it in my trouser pocket and I came to
this place where these women were all
aggregating and it was Friday night
suddenly the door opens and the woman
comes in and she had lymphedema of the
arm and it was swollen waiting well you
see people who had breast cancer
sometimes get all the lymph nodes of the
arm and axilla taken out and then they
may develop a stagnation of limp in
their arm and the arm will swell up
become quite hard and these arms are
very sensitive to infections and this is
called lymphedema most women are being
told well you have to live is it it's
better than to die from breast cancer
and there's nothing we can do but he's
for women have to watch very carefully
whether their arm gets infected and
oftentimes they have to wear gloves all
the time to do their work and can you
mention if a woman has her right hand
with which she has to do work she must
avoid any form of injury or else she
would get erysipelas infection which can
be very dangerous is a very unpleasant
condition and on this evening a woman
came and had a swollen are much worse
seriously inflamed and she was in pain
and blisters formed on it
she passed my table and they're simply
integrated on my biochemical knowledge I
said sit down
reached in my pocket gave her the
selenium and she took that selenium 800
micrograms s to remember today and then
she was sitting at our table and we
could actually was in 40 minutes or so
see how the inflammation disappeared and
how the swelling went down then within
12 hours the total swelling of the arm
was very very significantly reduced
practically to normal so we were of
cause excited and then since there were
so many women there with lymphedema we
did a study with 86 of these women and
could confirm yes inverse and is now an
accepted therapy in Europe for
lymphedema didn't work on all 86 it
works in a large percentage of these
patients of course you have some
patients who had lymphedema for many
years decades and then it hardens they
had calcium deposits but even they are
after longer dosages of selenium we
could still
Chifa softening even of old resistant
links the dima so it seemed everyone
today was certainly positive and then in
the meantime large-scale in clinical
studies were done in some clinics and
one of the key results was that selenium
does prevent the infections and so they
don't have to take antibiotics anymore
and this is of course a great
achievement and for this i received a
reward that brought me the idea that
selenium must have many many functions
in other diseases associated with
inflammation and so i first recommended
to use selenium in acute pancreatitis
which is another fatal disease you have
acute pancreatitis um big trouble and
selenium does significantly reduce the
mortality from acute pancreatitis then
the next very fatal condition is
septicemia and medical doctors in Europe
have shown in fact that selenium reduces
the mortality from septicemia especially
if accompanied by pneumonia now this is
her cousin achievement because basically
once you have septicemia pneumonia I
mean wherever it and you will my friend
but again a significant mortality
reduction was achieved so suddenly all
these terrible conditions became
treatable and so a company that produces
selenium drugs decided we have to
improve the knowledge of physicians in
selenium and stimulate the use in acute
medicine and therefore they said because
in honor of me they would nominate
people for the Schloss award if they
came up with similar usages of selenium
as I did last year in July in Berlin we
actually gave her way the first flowers
award to doctors of Oz Khan who
discovered another very important thing
and that is that selenium can reduce the
neurological damage subsequent to stroke
now you know very well that stroke is a
rather terrible thing to have but even
worse
is the subsequent damage of the brain
cells and leads to this often permanent
effects of stroke the paralyzation
that's right and this is caused by
oxygen radical damage to it into the
neuron and one can reduce that damage by
selenium so this is again another
example of how selenium works it's a
true miracle element and we haven't seen
the rest of it yet and many things to
come the story of selenium goes on like
I've never seen with any other trace
element usually in some survivors is
reported they have an initial increase
in research papers well and then you
know it stops in case of selenium during
the past 30 years it goes on and on and
on becomes more exciting almost every
week how much selenium when they using
what kind of dosage well in the acute
cases you have to use a little more and
they give about a thousand micrograms
intravenously often because seriously
ill patient cannot swallow germany is
leading in this application of selenium
i have to say yes i have to say how much
slinging do you personally use well you
know going back to our real interest in
selenium is a nutritional of what you
have to do is always make sure that you
have a healthy reserve of selenium in
your body in your liver in your heart
and that's where and therefore 300
micrograms to fall in micrograms a day
this is how much I'm taking now for 30
years so now there are some other
nutrients that help with the effects
this way of some synergistic nutrients
that's right what are some of those well
vitamin E for example is a well known
synergistic nutrient because you can
argue see if selenium doesn't catch all
the hydro peroxides you can still form
some oxygen radicals which are then
snatched by vitamin E and so vitamin E
can actually reduce the requirement for
selenium right you can use less than you
if you have vitamin E which so they have
a synergistic effect between selenium
and vitamin E then I have synergistic
effects within
selenium and iodine silent hormones the
proper function
of the thyroid you need selenium and
iodine the synergistic effect between
selenium and copper some synergism
between selenium and zinc
for best results people should be using
selenium and the rest of the 90
essential nutrients for general
maintenance just to maintain optimal
health all nutrients are necessary
that's that's probably the best advice I
can give you because a giving an
isolated nutrient is in a way not right
for example people are shown if you give
people too much just magnesium you get
into trouble with copper for example you
can induce a copper deficiency or also
reduce the iron so there has to be a
proper balance also calcium and
magnesium should be given not just
calcium the body maintains a pretty
sharp ratio between calcium and
magnesium the same thing I think is true
of iron copper yes you're right you see
there are people who for some reason had
iron deficiency anemia and giving them
iron alone didn't help but giving them
some copper suddenly improved their
condition why because copper is needed
for proper iron utilization utilization
is there a difference in the form of
selenium is an inorganic form versus a
cuneiform versus something from a plant
is there a difference in how the body
utilizes it yes there is a difference
and I think this is a very good question
because first of all we are talking
about nutrition what is the major
nutritional form of selenium see plants
don't need at least this is our present
knowledge don't need selenium for
growths they basically absorb it from
the soil altruistically to help animals
and humans actually an amazing
phenomenon in other words even at very
low selenium soil you still get grass
growing but the forage crops on selenium
toward soils are not healthy for the
animals and this society was discovered
in white muscle disease and in lamps for
example would erupt
this form of selenium that is in
grass is not inorganic it's in the
protein of the plant and it's in the
form primarily of an amino acid silly no
methionine
so it turns out that in fact the key in
nutritional form of selenium is organic
and celina methionine what does Selena
methionine do it's the only amino acid
and I cannot emphasize this enough which
can replace another amino acid in our
body methionine and therefore selenium
can be stored in the organism our
muscles which contain up to 40% of the
total amount of selenium in the body
contains the lenio min the form of
silina methionine and this is important
because if you give selenite to animals
or humans the body cannot make Selina
Mitani and therefore you cannot get that
selenium into the muscles and that's why
it's so very very important to have an
organic form of selenium in the form of
Selina Matheny and therefore we should
not even they circulated selenium is
already not the same because the body
cannot make Selina methylene so this is
a nutritional thought they are however
therapeutic form if you have you know
this is not the purpose here of our
discussion to talk too much about
therapy but selenite has been used and
is being used in medicine and animal
husbandry as a rapid form of selenium
that is infused or given to prevent
conditions so yes you can use sodium
selenite for therapy if you need rapid
effects like I used for the lymphedema
if someone has an inflamed condition you
cannot give a nutrient and expect rapid
result because it first has to be
metabolized you have to do something
other and you give selenite but for
nutritional supplementation as we
understand it Celina Busse I mean is the
form of selenium that should be given
and that was correctly recognized by the
people who did the large-scale cancer
prevention
Larry Clark they gave selenium in the
form of Semiramis I mean as it is found
in yeast and in this regard the study it
was very important because it was in
nutritional cancer prevention study and
so one should check over the label is it
in the form of Samina Missoni yes then
it is a nutritional form if somebody is
taking selenium supplements you
mentioned that they first have to be
metabolized we're taking enzymes help
yes in fact vitamin b6 will help enzymes
dependent on vitamin b6 will help to
metabolize selenium assigning into the
biologically active form you mentioned
that we store a large part of our
selenium 40% in our muscles I have heard
people that use selenium before they
workout and after they workout and they
don't have as much of the sore muscles
afterwards when I see some of these
joggers and when I see how their massage
their leg muscles I always have to
snigger because you know I told you I'm
taking selenium now for many years
muscle pain was something I experienced
after exercise ever since I took
selenium I don't even know what that is
muscle pain or muscle stiffness are
there other nutrients that help with
that as well and heard about calcium and
muscle cramps and Lakeridge yes well
that is something true cuts in magnesium
help and that is also very important in
talking about nutrition a lot of people
have encouraged people to take mega
doses of a single nutrient but in your
experience even experienced with the
world-renowned dr. Linus Pauling that
it's much better to take a broad
spectrum of nutrition and sometimes
taking mega doses of one can throw off
your balances and other nutrients isn't
that correct exactly and this is
especially true for vitamin C which is
now you know I'm one of the most popular
vitamins ever and many people take in my
opinion too much vitamin C because if
you take high doses of vitamin C it
causes a loss of copper and that is very
important because you can develop
aneurysm and which can be fatal and so
this is one reason why I am
against mega dosing vitamin C also for
another reason when you take large doses
of vitamin C the body lands to adapt to
the situation and excretes it more
rapidly if you then stop the body in
fact there will continue deplete the
organism vitamin C and you can get to
very dangerously low levels that's the
so-called rebound effect and lastly I'm
against the vitamin C over dosage and
we've done that study actually in San
Diego now vitamin C is a reducing agent
it uses up oxygen right now you need
oxygen who will denies that and the rest
studies before World War two were they
tested fighter pilots and these fighter
pilots didn't Avenue pressurized cabins
and they noticed that if they took some
vitamin C their high altitude resistance
would improve but if they took too much
of it it could would get much worse and
this was repeated and they'd indeed
showed that guinea pigs given too much
vitamin C had very low high altitude
simulated oxygen depletion resistance
and we repeated this with American
fighter pilots in San Diego at the Naval
Air Base and he could show that those
who had the burst high altitude
resistance was after dosage of high
doses of vitamin C so this is another
reason why I said don't let's do this
you talked with dr. Linus Pauling about
that did you see any of those effects in
him personally yes I knew Linus Pauling
very well of course and unlike so many
you take high doses of vitamin C it
causes your skin to become very pale
because it interferes with the melanin
production which requires a copper
dependent enzyme and so I don't serve
vitamin C we cannot rectum it I know
you've associated with a lot of very
prestigious scientists around the world
you've actually been listed as one of
the top 10 most quoted scientists in the
entire world what do you feel about your
association with dr. Wallach tell us a
little bit about
how you met him and how you feel about
some of the research that he has done
well you know John Walla became known to
me from the press in 1978 when he
announced it he discovered the first
animal model of cystic fibrosis in a
rhesus monkey and that was a wonderful
achievement because cystic fibrosis is
quite common in the human population and
you know people say yes when they really
don't know what something is caused by
they say it's genetic right and to this
day we haven't really gotten a really a
handle on cystic fibrosis because we
didn't have an animal model to create
conditions related to cystic fibrosis
which involves basra pancreatic atrophy
it was dr. kovala who actually developed
a rhesus monkey model of cystic fibrosis
and when he announced this he said that
this discovery is relevant to human
cystic fibrosis and some of the old
hands and cystic fibrosis researcher
what how can he possibly say that
selenium and vitamin E deficiency would
be causing cystic fibrosis cystic
fibrosis is a genetic disease as nothing
you can do about it and poor dr. Walla
who lost his job in the ACA's Primate
Research Center and when I read this in
the American press I got so furious and
I thought to myself this is so terrible
that someone is being fired for
proposing something for voicing an idea
which in this case was even supported by
an experiment at that time I was
organizing an international conference
at the University of California and I
invited dr. Wallach to give a talk and I
still remember he invited really the
cream of the crop of trace element
research in the world it was 1979 and
dr. wallop gave an extremely
well-received lecture on his tea
for cystic fibrosis and this helped him
greatly in fact to overcome the stigma
of having been you know openly dismissed
and since then we became the best of
friends and it's a wonderful
collaboration that has developed some 25
years of happy friendship really and if
you add now my previous interest in
colloidal minerals and work it makes it
almost an unbelievable coincidence that
the two of us have met as somehow we
were placed together to work together if
I use cysts
well dr. shatter just to conclude this
message we've heard a lot of the
research that you've shared with us that
you've come across why isn't the public
aware of this why don't more doctors
publish these and the medical community
make a bigger deal about it yes well
this is a very difficult question to
answer why is that because it takes
surprisingly long before a message sinks
in into the medical community take
cardiomyopathy usually adopters see
patients much too late in other words
when they already dying of
cardiomyopathy then they have to do all
kinds of things including surgery or
whatever therefore they're not really
interested in nutrition they say why
should I consider nutrition these
patients are dying after do surgery for
example and so when you tell them hey
why don't you give them selenium they
never see patients before they developed
a cardiomyopathy which meant eight years
and I think this is the real issue at
the core of this situation then medical
doctors see everybody far too late
chronic diseases require many years
before they actually become manifest and
this is where nutrition comes in and
this is where I think the recommendation
of taking selenium and other minerals
becomes so important because we have to
tell healthy people before any sign of
disease is noticeable take your selenium
take your minerals take them now and you
will not ever land in the heart clinic
with cardiomyopathy right so we use all
the protective
patís of minerals in time as they do in
veterinary medicine already for you so I
think part of our message today is not
only for people to supplement with
selenium but to help us take this
message to other people as well because
the medical community is not doing it
absolutely it's like talking to the
wrong agency right you're talking to the
Rotter agency about your gas stove they
will say well you're a nice guy we like
you but we have nothing to do with gas
stoves and the same thing I believe is
ultimately if you go to a practicing
doctor and you say what can I do about
cardiomyopathy well and what can he tell
you he's not a nutritionist he has his
hands full to do with acute cases and so
you will say well I don't know well
don't do anything and this is where we
come in we can say no no no this good
nutrition and mineral supplementation
you will never get this conduct do you
have any last experiences that you would
like to share with us well I already
mentioned for instance a muscular pain
has completely disappeared I never have
it but maybe I should store that one in
I was little nearsighted
in my thirties and they often had to sit
in the front row during lecture so I
could see they read the slides and I was
afraid you know in California we have to
take driver's license examinations every
three and they test your eyes and they
would have said God you need glasses and
so when I took selenium suddenly my
eyesight improved so much that all these
problems disappeared and they remained
so today I don't need glasses and I've
subsequently and talked to many people
who take selenium and many of them say
the same thing that their eyesight
improved and our studies was the
lymphedema patients show the same thing
the service what about money
yes and that is also important you know
the brain needs selenium and in fact
selenium and finding specifically goes
into the brain so this is a very
important fact and I'm glad you brought
that up because studies have shown if
you put humans on a low selenium diet
they become depressed and if you give
them selenium their mood stabilizers a
blip
gone so it is absolutely essential for
brain function and it helps you with
moon and we've seen that also in our
studies with the HIV infected fish they
reported hey I'm no longer depressed
what did that for children selenium
point for children absolutely and you
see this is one of my great concerns
because she in the first four or five
months in life of babies their blood
selenium levels go down often to very
very low levels almost real you know are
cute efficiency levels and then they
increase slowly but this is true for
European or you could say Western and
Australian children interesting enough
is not true for Japanese children
they're the selenium levels are high to
begin with and never show that initial
decline so from this I judge that indeed
our selenium supply is dangerously low
because children should never go through
a period where they are selenium levels
in the blood is very low it should
always be high to begin with so that
they can really utilize the protective
functions of selenium so every period in
their life is that one of the reasons
you see a lot of hair infections in
small children well it's well known they
say the immune system has not yet
matured and all that sort of thing but
we know my friend without selenium your
immune system does not work selenium is
required for all functions of the immune
system I cannot emphasize this enough
and unfortunately in pediatric nutrition
selenium is in my opinion grossly
underestimated and neglected so I think
doctors taking 300 or 400 micrograms a
day how much would you have any
hindrance well an infants there are some
recommendations 20 micrograms a day is
probably okay I would however say that
if it is the nutritional form of
selenium first of all there's not much
danger of toxicity anyway so 20 to 50
micrograms for children per day would be
perfect right and then especially in a
sink of teenagers what they need they
grow rapidly and they're like adults and
don't forget our weight has increased
over the
last three decades many of our
discussions are dealing with average
rates yet DRD eggs are not really
specifying the weight of the subject
Mohammed Ali and Michael Jackson have
the same selenium requirement ridiculous
the heavy man must need more selenium
right what did that expecting many
absolutely essential and again
veterinary medicine has shown this to be
true because selenium is the key element
guaranteeing the healthy birthing of
calves for example and also the reduces
the incidence of placental retention
which is a very unpleasant thing to
happen very costly because these animals
must be treated plus I'd pull retention
also occurs in humans my friend you can
prevented with selenium so women in in
pregnancy require selenium yes well
trying to micrograms a day very very
important thank you very much for your
time today dr. Shah sir we look forward
to hearing from you again
[Music]
you